[Musique]
ils étaient plus de sous dans le 3 août
et mélisande
dans son jeu derrière j'entends tous mes
clés tout leur faire intégrer match
permet sur la vie de ma mère je les
doubleurs parce que j'aime n'ont réglé
mettez-moi couleurs de l'egypte a
proposé à ce que ce soir bon ben ouais
la surface est allé attaquer way devrait
en faire une après on m'a dit tu
rajoutes un bandeau broshing nom qu'a
choisi ce nom des moules à ses moules a
coûté un moule à osamu là
[Musique]
la comédie c'est quoi le délire
alain côté que renoir perdre à chaillot
[Musique]
sans tourner à chaud on voit la vie
voilà bible alice attendons le [ __ ]
dvg nom de méchant à andré j'attende sur
sept est payant je vais tout de suite
est tout de suite tombé là bas voilà mes
jeux en bois ça parce que c'est vous qui
se rapproche le plus de l'onu en guinée
c'est qu'au mali d'où elle opère
pendant de la gagne non mais oh la la
[Musique]